the big y is the reason why you're doing
the thing that you're doing if you feel
like the work that you're doing is
important is touching lives is is
meaningful as making a difference that
can get you through a lot of stress you
tell yourself this is just a warm-up
it's just a mind trick
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so to help you on your
journey today I'm gonna look at seven
ways to overcome stress that can help
you both immediately and in the long
term enjoy so entrepreneurs are among
the most stressed out people on the
planet you're doing this thing that is
impossible you're trying to create a new
world that doesn't exist you've got
people who are butting against you and
telling you that you can't do it and
offering you yourself this little voice
on your shoulder saying you can't do it
some days they're there some things are
not and so stress is part of the job as
part of the business and I want to share
with you the seven ways that I found
really helpful to overcome it in the
short run things you can do immediately
and in the long run
[Music]
so let's kick it off with way number one
put on music music is the fastest way
that I know how to change your state
whenever I'm feeling depressed or low or
down or unsure or lack of confidence or
I just feel like I need a little bit
more of an energy boost the fastest way
that I know how is to put on music and
so there's no one song that will work I
create a believe playlist it's public
you can go check it out but the songs
that I love may not be the ones that you
guys love here's what you want to do
find the songs that build you up finds
it songs that when they come on you want
to you want to jam to them find the
songs that when they come on you want to
sing out loud that's what you want to do
when you are down when you are low and
you're stressed out when you are
incapable of doing anything because
you're so in your head that's what you
want to do you want to bounce you want
to move you want to jump you want to
sing at the top of your lungs because
this amazing song has come on and so
making the playlist in advance of you
getting stressed out is really helpful
so that when you are stressed you don't
have to be searching through YouTube
trying to find music that will cause
more stress and make the playlist in
advance so that when you are stressed
out you can put it on and you can
instantly get rid of it
[Music]
wait number two is remember the big why
the big why is the reason why you're
doing the thing that you're doing this
I'll offer you is if I'm feeling
stressed or overwhelmed or I'm unhappy
or something went wrong or you know we
lost a client if somebody left the
negative comment whatever it is it's
remembering why I'm doing it what's the
big why what are you trying to
accomplish I'm trying to solve the
world's biggest problem untapped human
potential that's what I'm trying to do
and then remembering that if you're
trying to do something new something big
something nobody has done before you're
gonna have a lot of problems where
incent me a lot of mistakes is gonna be
a lot of forging a new path and when
you're forging that new path there's
gonna be difficulties everything great
ever accomplished came on the other side
of a lot of difficulties and failure and
so remembering the big why helps you
deal with the short term stresses and
immediacy of the problems that you're
facing you're basically able to step
above what you're doing and say hey
we've run into an obstacle here but
we're still moving forward this is why
having a big why is so important this is
why following your passion is so
important because if you don't have that
[ __ ] anchor that is you're pulling
towards you're gonna quit because it's
gonna get insanely difficult and that's
why a lot of entrepreneurs quit because
they only did the business trying to
chase an opportunity as opposed to
having that deep powerful strong why
purpose passion for the business that
they're doing so actually we feel
overwhelmed just remind yourself that
you are trying to accomplish something
big and that doesn't happen without
going through some adversities we number
three is I remember the little why so
the big why's the purpose what you're
trying to accomplish on a big scale the
challenge that I found is sometimes
sometimes the big why seems overwhelming
sometimes the big why of trying to solve
the world's biggest problem for me is
it's just it's never gonna happen
it's too big a deal it's if I'm feeling
low or downs like it's it's it's
impossible to ever reach that and so
sometimes it can be massively inspiring
most of the time but sometimes they can
also just pile on the stress if you feel
like you're not able to do it or to
accomplish it then who are you to go off
and make this big thing happen sometimes
the Y can actually be demotivating and
so what I do is then you look at the
little whys and so if the big wife for
me is trying to solve the world's
biggest problem the little Y's are the
daily comments to live
are going to my YouTube channel and
seeing people leaving comments every
single day about the impact that my
videos have had the little wire your
customers leaving you feedback leaving a
yelp review or a Google review or
sending you an email saying how much you
helped them the little wires just in the
day-to-day knowing that the work that
you're doing is important if you feel
like the work that you're doing is
important is touching lives is is
meaningful as making a difference that
can get you through a lot of stress but
if you're stressed out to the max and
you feel like the work you're doing
doesn't matter that nobody cares nobody
will ever care then it's really hard to
keep going and so I find between that
mix of big why and little why the big
purpose of where I'm going and on a
daily basis knowing that it made a
difference to that one person liked that
one comment doesn't mean anything but it
just means that I helped that one person
that one person is impacted by the thing
that I made and that allows me that
actually a little motivational boost and
the reduce the stress though to know
that hey if I keep going more glue
comments will come way number four is
deal with the biggest stress or whatever
the thing is is causing you so much
stress I've learned to deal with it if
you can immediately deal with it then
it's much more likely to reduce your
stress everywhere else so for example
for me a lot of times my stresses come
around people and having difficult
conversations and I used to avoid
difficult conversations that you should
to put them up I used to to wait and
hold off and maybe the problem with its
itself and that very rarely happened and
it just leads to more stress and I would
lose sleep over it I would have I used
to have to take stress pills because of
it just so worried about other people
and their reaction and wanting them to
to be a success and so the thing that
I've really leaned in on is dealing with
that stressor so if I have to have a
difficult conversation then I'll find a
way to have that conversation today if
I'm trying to connect with somebody and
I know I'm not gonna meet with them
until next week or two weeks on the line
I'll try to reject the calendar and
schedule so that I'm connecting with
them today to get it off my plate to
deal with that difficult conversation
then let the stress out it today and
then not have to stress for the next two
weeks thinking about this thing
so whatever the thing is causing you so
much stress find the fastest way to be
able to deal with it ideally today so
you can deal with it and move on and
push through we number five is tell
yourself this is just a warm-up this is
something that I got from the fitness
workout community where people who are
lifting weights would tell themselves
this is just a warm-up even though it's
the heaviest set of weights that you've
ever done you tell yourself this is just
a warm-up it's just a mind trick and so
I found that that actually helps when
I'm working out that this is just a
warm-up that I'm able to do some extra
reps I'm able to pedal a little bit
harder that I'm able to push myself just
a little bit further because I remind
myself this is just a warm-up it's a
it's a subconscious trigger to tell
yourself that you were capable of more
that if you want to go off and solve a
big problem that if you think this big
thing in front of you is big then you're
not able to do bigger problems or if you
realize that this problem is not that
big then you're capable of doing more so
if I'm worried if I'm stressed out if
I'm thinking about a conversation that I
have to have then I'll work to try to
have that conversation as soon as
possible and until it happens I'll tell
myself this is not a big deal this is
just a warm-up I am capable of handling
bigger things and this thing in front of
me and that mindset shift helps reduce
the stress until I'm able to deal with
the actual stressor which is having the
conversation we number six is to adjust
your schedule if I am constantly getting
stressed out then I need to adjust my
schedule I know it's a problem with the
work that I'm actually doing with the
people that I'm surrounding myself with
with some of the tasks that I've chosen
to take on I find that anytime I get
stressed it comes down to looking at my
calendar and seeing where is the problem
what is causing me this consistent
stress if it's a one-off
stress then okay let's find you could
deal with it but it's when it's
consistent if something that's
constantly stressing you out like a bad
employee or business partner or you know
whoever it is you need to deal with it
look at your calendar look at your
schedule look at the actions and the
habits that you're taking you don't want
to have a source of consistent stress
and if there is one then you need to
eliminate it so I'm a big fan of running
a no crisis business I try to eliminate
as many crises as possible
I don't want to work with clients who
demand my immediate attention I have
fired clients who need me to be on call
24/7 who expect you to be able to answer
to an email that they have in 30 seconds
after they send it I don't want to work
with those people and I get that's their
style I have total empathy for it but I
don't want to be working in that kind of
relationship because it'll cause me
stress now the flip side is if you're
not getting back to somebody
ASAP then you need to provide so much
value the work that you do has to be
insanely amazing that they can deal with
it but I don't want to work with those
kinds of clients I don't have a cell
phone number you know I have a phone but
there's no number I just have data so I
can post a social media respond to you
guys but I don't have a number a phone
numbers other people's agenda for your
time I don't want to be stressed out and
when I'm working on when I'm making this
video I don't want somebody interrupting
and calling me and then I have to do the
video over again or even it's on silent
mode and I just see this thing pop up I
wonder huh who's calling or if I know
them I'm thinking what do they want it's
other people's agenda for your time you
don't control your time when you have a
phone number and that might be a really
radical extreme thing and you don't have
to necessarily adopt it but I would say
if there is a consistent form of stress
in your life whether it's people whether
it's activities look at your calendar
look at where you're spending your time
and you want to reduce and eliminate it
as much as possible
wine offs are still gonna happen as
you're trying out new things going on
new paths forging new roads new stresses
will come but anything is consistent you
need to deal with and handle and
eliminate
[Music]
and we number seven is create an
environment for success so what I would
look at is what are the things that are
causing you the most stress and then
creating an environment where you're
surrounding yourself with people
resources ideas that help you shift your
mindset around it so as an example for
me if I'm if I'm worried about having
difficult conversations with people it
was a big fear was a big stress a big
concern for me the more I surrounded
myself with videos and a lot of them
have been on that this channel the more
I watched those videos of people having
difficult conversations the more it
built up my own confidence my own
courage now I'm surrounding myself with
people who are having difficult
conversations this becomes part of my
identity I'm around people who are doing
this I see the positive impact it's
having it gives me the confidence and
the courage to go off and do it and now
I stress out about it less and so
whatever the thing is that is causing
you stress seeing people have success
doing it the mindset and the approach
that they have watching that on a
consistent basis and for me I think I
think videos are the best
I think visual really helps I think
being able to see somebody do it as
opposed to just hear somebody or just
read it I think is the best medium do
your own thing more important than than
picking video over over podcasting over
books is just doing something
consistently that you are now
surrounding yourself with the thing that
you want to get better at if you are in
that environment you will automatically
get better if you around people who are
better than you add that thing your
skill level will rise up it has to
that's how it works you are a product of
your environment and so if you're
unhappy with something instead of always
thinking about it shifting your
environment so that it automatically
happens can be a huge win so those are
my seven ways and how to overcome stress
I would love to know which one resonated
most with you that you can apply to your
situation and did I miss an 8 9 10 that
you want to add to the list put it down
in the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you soon if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it don't you believe it you
act like I am Tulsa what a wail out of a
handcuffed lightning both under
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty-four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 2:54
confidence or every single day for two
hundred fifty four days I will be
sending you a video between thirty
seconds and five minutes long that you
start your morning with around making
you feel confident it's absolutely free
check out the link in the description
below to get access